police searching for the missing girl
Nicola bully are appearing for a
potentially key witness who is in the
area at the time to come forward he's
described as a white man in his 70s who
was walking a dog close to where she
disappeared the mother of two was last
seen just after nine o'clock on Friday
morning in Saint Michael's on wire in
Lancashire let's go live there now and
speak to Sky's Katarina vitotsi and uh
Katarina talk to us about this latest a
specific appeal for a witness to come
forward
yes well the extensive police search for
Nicole Willie has continued in and
around the small village of Saint
Michael on wire the river wire that runs
through that Village we've seen
fingertip searches in undergrowth and
we've seen police dive teams as well
looking for the mother of two who
disappeared shortly after 9 15 a.m on
Friday morning and that search going on
now for the past five days and now an
appeal for a key witness that police say
they are especially Keen to speak to
this is the statement we've had from
Lancashire police just within the last
hour where they've said we are
especially Keen to find a witness we
believe was in the area at the time
Nicola went missing he is described as a
man aged around 70 white six foot tall
well built who was walking a small white
fluffy dog on a lead he spoke to a woman
in the area the statement continues
before walking in the direction of Rowan
water if this is you you or if you know
who this could be please get in touch
we've been down at the scene where
Nicola bully went missing on Friday
morning or the place I should say where
she was last seen and is an area
extremely popular with dog walkers we
know that Nicola bully was last seen
there with her small bat spaniel Willow
who was found shortly after Nicola bully
herself disappeared and this now
appealed from Lancashire police for that
key witness a man walking a small dog on
that same footpath that they believe was
in the area when the mother of two went
missing
also been speaking to some friends of
Nicholas
the galvanized by Nicholas friends and
family down at the place where she was
last seen we met some of those friends
Emma White and Heather Gibbons who
described her as a woman deeply
entrenched within this small community
part of the primary school Community
where her two children aged nine and six
were pupils here is what they told us
read anxious every emotion going it's a
roller coaster and
the communities all out searching the
community we can't thank you enough from
the family and friends and everyone's
pulled together at the moment it's such
a roller coaster you're trying to hold
on to Hope because she obviously at the
current time know nothing and and you
want to hold on to the hope that no news
is good news
um but knowing Nikki we just know that
if she could be at home with the girls
we very firmly believe that's where
she'd be you go from being hopeful to
being heartbroken to being and just
trying to be strong because all we want
is to find a for our girls and football
she'd do anything for anybody and she's
in the community she's she's doing
things you know she's well loved within
the school community and any mommy's
nights out she she is there and
organizing it as well she's just one of
those real salt of the earth people who
is so kind
in this new statement from Lancashire
police we should also add that they say
at this time this remains a missing
person inquiry there is nothing to
suggest any third party involvement in
Nicholas disappearance at this time the
police going on to stress for any
witnesses to come forward who may have
seen Nicola bully and that area that she
was last seen on Friday morning or have
any dash cam footage that may show her
walking along the road around that time
to come forward
thanks so much